somehow twitch streamers and hot tubs
has become one of the most popular
things on the platform recently
one of those streamers indie fox has
been banned from twitch
four times for more or less breaking
twitch's dress code
her bands and the rise of this hot tub
meta
has reignited debates not only about
twitch's terms of service
but how to best understand the insane
rules
on this platform
i often wonder if just randomly yelling
instead of telling you to like the video
sub to the channel and hit that
notification bell would
actually work i mean you should do all
those things if you haven't already
but you know just a thought also if you
have a story you want to see here on
don't at me
send a tip to tips at thescore.com so
indie fox started streaming on twitch
back in 2017
and at first she dabbled in irl
streaming while playing
games from time to time but as her
twitch career evolved over the years
she's become a
staple in the just chatting category hey
i'm indie fox
and this is my twitch gaming setup
welcome to my office now just chatting
is by far
the most popular section on twitch and
wardrobe
is often a hot topic of both
conversation
and bannings amongst that category's top
streamers
it's chaotic the dudes are thirsty as
[ __ ]
and there is a ton going on that is
trying to just
skate by twitch's historically vague
terms of service
in fact twitch actually updated its
attire and nudity policy in 2020
thanks in large part to just chatting
we'll talk more about that in just a bit
and while indie fox rode this rising
wave to an average viewership of 6 000
people often peaking close to 20k with
close to 500 000 followers it also
landed her in
hot water like getting banned from the
platform four
times kind of hot water her first band
came in january of this year where she
streamed from an inflatable hot
tub to ten thousand viewers
garrick yeah thank you for the five
months in a row
yes thank you thank you that clip and
streamer jake and bake's commentary
exploded on the live stream fails
subreddit and
shortly after that indie fox was hit
with a three-day ban
now while twitch didn't state
specifically what rules indie fox
violated here's what the tos has to say
about see-through clothing
quote we don't permit streamers to be
fully or partially nude
including exposing genitals or buttocks
end quote
indie fox responded to the idea that the
swimsuit was see-through saying that it
wasn't
while also poking fun at jake and bake
in the process
then less than 24 hours after her
three-day suspension
ended indie fox was banned again after
streaming from her bed
writing the names of people donating all
over her body with a marker
something that she had done quite a few
times on stream before
no this is the skin safe ink it's makeup
this too blew up on live stream fails
but
this time indie fox fired back at the
subreddit for being toxic
harassing her and from misconstruing
what she was doing on stream
her third band came on february 23rd
this time wearing what she would
normally be wearing while also playing
guitar on her bed
this time indie fox went after twitch
saying she felt targeted by
the platform because in her mind she had
done nothing wrong
now indie fox's recent bands and her
rise in popularity coincides with this
hot dub twitch meta
which also has become extremely popular
it's hard to pinpoint exactly where this
all started
but since late last year hot tubs have
been building a following
and so is the controversy that's come
with it from exo ariel to amaranth
mia malkova to kiara kitty who's also
been
banned for some hot tubs have come to
dominate the front page of twitch [ __ ]
hot tub streams have gotten so
popular even v-tubers are getting in on
the action
hot tub streams have hit that point in
their popularity where people are now
arguing over who started the trend indie
fox threw shade at
amaranth and other streamers for copying
her content
they fired back at her saying the exact
same thing
meanwhile xo ariel told kotaku it was
actually her who started the trend
this meta has also reignited a debate
about what women should be allowed to
wear
and do on the platform on one hand you
have streamers like qt cinderella who
say that while
yes streamers should be able to get that
money
this hot tub meta promotes sexism and
it's bad for the platform
like i'm all about getting that bread i
am i really am
i'm like yes queen do the hot tub stream
but please don't do it on twitch
because it makes my life miserable but
on the other hand you have streamers
like xo ariel who agrees with qt
cinderella that women
shouldn't have to face the harassment
they're currently dealing with
but disagrees that hot tub twitch
streams are the problem
well i agree with her to some extent i.e
men over sexualizing the women on the
platform
and just overall being sexist i don't
agree that we the females are to blame
for this
then there was this tweet from miss
banana ts
that blew up on twitter and caused a
fierce debate
all over social media and here's a clip
from the real housewives of twitch
podcast debating the issue people are
asking us all the time
are you making an only fans are you
making a feeling only fans do you have
only feet
are you selling nudes stuff like that
yes it is
absolutely seeping into us and it is
it's constant sexual harassment
when i have to deal with that [ __ ] but
you're blaming me
you're blaming your women for that
you're blaming me for that
you're blaming women for doing that
you're not even blaming the men who are
pieces of [ __ ] you're blaming
women for doing that for making money
from there the conversation spread like
wildfire
and of course you had the usual suspects
like hassan
ms kiff and xqc giving their hot takes
do you really expect and want them to
clothe more on purpose to get less
success on purpose
because you're mad that they have an
advantage that you don't have people
clapping
and they use it to make up for them
for the fact that they work against
that's weird that's just
but this [ __ ] even spread to people like
everyone's favorite dad
hiko who honestly was spitting straight
facts
i saw there's like a teacher that got
mad that they opened twitch and
on the front page there's a girl in a
hot tub and i guess
that was they didn't like that but i
mean
it's easy you just don't watch if you
don't like the content don't watch
i feel like twitch is the only place
where people people are vocal about the
things they don't like to watch
honestly this hot dub twitch meta seems
like all anyone can talk about at the
moment
it's the scantily clad elephant in the
room what do you think about hot tub
girls
fine okay
what do you think of them fine now let's
talk about twitch's tos for a second
prior to updating its attire and nudity
policy around this time last year
twitch's rules about what you couldn't
and could wear on the platform
was vague at best and not surprisingly
this led to a lot of streamers getting
banned and not really knowing
why this update was supposed to bring
more specificity to twitch's policies
here's an excerpt quote we do not permit
the visible outline of genitals even
when
covered broadcasting nude or partially
nude miners is always prohibited
regardless of context
for those who present as women we ask
that you cover your nipples
we do not permit exposed underbust
cleavage is unrestricted as long as
these coverage requirements are met
for all streamers you must cover the
area extending from your hips
to the bottom of your pelvis and
buttocks now in my opinion there's
nothing wrong with this hot tub twitch
meta
and the argument that if you don't want
to be harassed don't do these type of
streams
is honestly [ __ ] ridiculous and like
heco said
if you don't like it just don't watch it
but also let's be honest this hot tub
meta
is clearly a loophole in twitch's tos
even with the more specific policies in
place
we've seen streamers banned before for
far more innocuous things like
body painting for example or cosplaying
as chun
li and this is something asthma gold
pointed out on twitter
he also talked about how twitch has
handled these bands stating that they've
created a narrative that
some streamers are allowed to get away
with things while others would be
permabanned for that exact same thing
and this has been a long time complaint
of many streamers about the platform
and i think they need to do something
about it because it
the reason why they need to do something
about it is that every single other
person sees that
and it creates this discontent and
that's why i think that unfairness
is so it's so insidious it's so
subversive that it infects the entire
population
even when over when whenever it only
effects
a small amount of the population now
speaking of twitch's tos
let's get back to indie fox and her most
recent band which happened on april
7th the reason this time is even more
vague than the last
three in the email twitch sent her it
states that indie fox broke community
guidelines by quote
selling twitch services or features end
quote the email specifies that this
could mean
any one of the following things offering
a channel moderator role to a user if
they donate to you
offering to raid or host another
streamer if they subscribe to your
channel
and advertising that you will follow a
channel in exchange for a gifted
subscription
not surprisingly indie fox was extremely
confused and said that she didn't do
any of these things and like all of
these vague twitch
emails it doesn't state the specific
incident that got her banned
now some people in her replies to her
tweet said that setting a price for vip
status counts as selling which is
apparently against community guidelines
one person suggested she do what other
streamers have done in the past
and just give vip status to viewers who
heavily support her channel
vip if you didn't know is a special
status that streamers can give to people
who are long time supporters
or to people who are just really active
in their communities
at the time of recording twitch has yet
to explicitly address the hot tub meta
and what
if anything it's going to do about it
and that's the crux of this controversy
it's not about what women are allowed to
do with their bodies on stream because
they should be able to do whatever the
[ __ ] they want
and it has everything to do with the way
twitch regulates what
is and isn't acceptable on stream
come on camera okay you all get that
that is darth vader
almost had it all right here we go
somehow twitch